this is really one of the most
remarkable confrontations of a
republican delusion that i've seen in a
long time
and it took place on fox news no doubt
a fox news host neil cavuto asked
former republican senator kelly lefler
remember her
really the perfect question about her
claims
that there were problems and
irregularities
in the 2020 election in georgia in which
she was a candidate and lost to rafael
warnock and the question is really
simple if there were problems
with the trump versus biden results and
they can't be trusted
because the georgia secretary of state
brad raffensberger was a partisan and
biased arbiter of that election
he supported you kelly leffler in that
race
what does that mean isn't that an
obvious conflict now
remember that i brought this up a
similar version of this
back in november just after the election
when i tweeted quote
why have trump and republicans accepted
the results
from house and senate elections but not
presidential
everything was on the same ballots in
other words tons of republicans who won
in the house and senate on the same
ballots as where trump lost
were saying we cannot trust these
results it's rigged
this there's all sorts of irregularities
but so hold on we also can't trust that
you won right and of course that's not
what they were talking about an obvious
problem with their argument so let's now
get to the video of neil cavuto
who reduces kelly leffler to mumbling
and stumbling by pointing out you know
the guy
you're saying needs to be investigated
for his role in the election
he supported you in that race and of
course part of the implication here
is maybe he did something screwy to help
you as well
right take a look at this just a
remarkable
60 seconds of footage making sure that
everyone's voice is heard
all right so if we have an investigation
into that it would be investigations
after other investigations this one more
focused i guess on the behavior of mr
rethensberger but
um you would charge that you want to
probe into whether he used his office to
as
advance his political interest he was
supporting you
and and and your your colleague so
how was that opposite what
your interests were you were both on the
same page
that's not exactly correct i mean look
he's our top elections official he's not
a partisan official per se but my focus
is
he wasn't for you but he wasn't for your
opponent right senator he was for you
he was first under purdue what would be
in his interest to sabotage that
not not suggesting sabotage i'm
suggesting that
georgians don't trust voting right now
and he took actions that led to a lack
of confidence
wow well if brad raffensberger
took actions that led to a lack of
confidence
and he supported kelly leffler we should
be looking into whether kelly lefler
really only lost by a little bit to
rafael warnock maybe kelly lefler lost
by a lot
but brad raffensberger in the same way
that he maybe pulled funny business
against trump
because he didn't like trump this is
their story
maybe he pulled some funny business in
favor of david perdue and kelly lefler
who he supported now of course what's
the truth here
the truth is i think kelly leffler knows
the georgia election was pretty fair
trump simply lost she has sort of played
coy with all of this stuff because
remember
that there was that period between
november and january
where kelly lefler and david perdue were
campaigning for those special elections
she was fighting for her political life
between november and january 5th which
was the day of that special election
and during that time she needed donald
trump's support
at least she believed she needed it i
don't know maybe it hurt more than it
helped
so she was playing coy with the election
fraud stuff when she was
asked directly whether she agreed with
donald trump that the election in
georgia was rigged i think during the
debate with rafael warnock it came up
she would say stuff like well we need to
investigate
the president has every right to demand
this and that
to his satisfaction that this was done
correctly and that was done correctly we
need to ensure
every vote every legal vote is counted
and every voice is heard
she was playing coy with it to avoid
having to say
no i think trump's telling you but then
that risks losing the trump support she
thought she needed in that
special election in january i believe
she doesn't care about trump
i think she cares about herself i think
kelly lefler probably recognizes that
trump's a disaster but if trump is
useful to her if it helps her win
then she'll say whatever and accept
donald trump's support she might want to
run again
and she's probably looking at the same
polls we're looking at which show
that at least for right now donald trump
is a player in republican politics
she might need trump's help if she wants
to run again
and she's going to keep playing coy and
continuing to be unable to just answer
simple questions or enable
refusing to uh questions like this one
which is you know the guy you're saying
we need to investigate
supported you in 2020. so where does
that leave us
with any of this nonsense i was hoping
that the last we'd see of kelly leffler
was when she lost to rafael warnock in
january
appears not to be the case and she is
truly
detestable and so horrible for the
country
and seems as determined as ever to get
involved again and to do more damage you
almost get the sense
that kelly lefler is like surprised
she's being asked this question on fox
which i mean listen
it's sort of surprising but occasionally
neil cavuto will ask what we would call
a real
question that in other countries just
every interview would have real
questions like this
and she's asked a so-called real
question
and she's unable to string together
anything approximating a coherent
response because
her position on this is and has been
incoherent
incoherent like trump she may run again
and we will need to fight her if that's
indeed what happens
i spend a lot of time every day looking
at a computer screen and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that
blue light from screens can lead to eye
strain
blurred vision headaches dry watery eyes
that will not be a problem for you once
you get blue blocks
glasses which filter out blue light to
help your
eyes they are one of our sponsors today
blue blocks glasses are developed and
built
in actual optics labs they've been
extensively tested for effectiveness
there are over 40 different styles to
choose from
these are my blue blocks glasses i like
the look i've noticed a huge difference
where i'm not
getting that eye strain or the headaches
from the computer screen
because of the blue blocks glasses they
really have something for everyone a
prescription version
non-prescription reading glasses and
blue blocks
is giving you twenty percent off when
you go to blue blocks dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is right underneath this video and you
will get free shipping on orders over
a hundred and fifteen dollars